bienvenido a mi presentación de división
de fracciones y antes de empezar a hacer
un montón de división de fracciones y
antes de profundizar más este concepto
quiero pensar un poco de una manera
mecánica que entiendas bien cómo se hace
una división de fracciones y ya con esto
pueden resolver el módulo de división de
fracciones que tenemos en esta página
así que empecemos imagínate que yo tengo
un medio un medio dividido entre un
medio ok bueno hay varias formas de
hacer esto podemos hacer la regla del
moño cruzar esto algo así podemos tomar
nuestra ley del sar luís pero a mí lo
que más me gusta es pensarlo como el
inverso el inverso multiplicativo lo que
quiero que entiendas muy bien en este
vídeo es que la definición de división
de fracciones está muy ligada a la
definición de multiplicación de
fracciones dividir una fracción entre
otra es muy parecido de hecho es lo
mismo que multiplicar por el inverso
multiplicar de la fracción que está
dividiendo cómo es eso imagínate aquí
tengo un medio entre un medio qué tal si
nos tomamos el inverso multiplicativo de
un medio y bueno cuando tomamos el
inverso multiplicativo lo que hay que
hacer es volteando es decir me va a
quedar 2 sobre 1 y entonces me voy a
tomar un medio y en lugar de poner entre
voy a poner x por 2 sobre 1 me tome el
inverso multiplicativo de un medio
déjame ponerlo aquí el inverso el
inverso y pasó de estar dividiendo a
estar multiplicando porque nosotros ya
sabemos y yo espero que ya hayas visto
el vídeo de multiplicación de fracciones
y multiplicar por fracciones es muy
fácil lo único que hay que hacer es
multiplicar este por este y ese por éste
es decir que 1 por 2 es 2 2 por unas 2 y
2 entre 2 por cierto es 1 un medio por
dos es lo mismo que uno y eso pues claro
que lo sabemos es un número por su
inverso multiplicativo me va a dar 1
pero ya tenemos también el resultado de
un medio entre un medio un medio entre
un medio es 1 y tiene toda la lógica del
mundo porque algo entre ese mismo algo
es siempre uno si entre sines 13 entre 3
es uno un medio entre un medio es 1 y
está de lujo no para dividir dos
fracciones tenemos que multiplicar
fracciones y de hecho creo que esto te
puede expandir mucho tu mente y ahora
creo que puedes entenderlo de manera
distinta cuánto es 2 entre 2 2 entre 2
tú no puedes pensar como el 2 por el
inverso multiplicativo de este 2 a este
2 lo voy a convertir en su metro
multiplicativo que es un medio y bueno 2
entre 2 sabemos que es 1 pero dos por un
medio también es 1 y ya está acabamos de
probar que 2 entre 2 es lo mismo que 1
utilizando el inverso multiplicativo y
voy a hacer un montón de ejemplos acerca
de esto así que no quiero que habrá
temas la cabeza en estos ejemplos
piensan los un rato y me voy a ir a un
siguiente pizarrón en donde vamos a
resolver el siguiente problema imagínate
que tengo 12 entre entre 4 entre 4 tú
sabes cuánto es esto 2 entre 4 sabemos
que es 3 pero qué te parece si ahora lo
pensamos con esta misma idea del inverso
multiplicativo vamos a tomarnos el
inverso de 4 el inverso de 4 bueno pues
4 es lo mismo que cuatro sobre 1 y si me
tomo el inverso es un cuarto un cuarto
recuerda que pasó este 4 para abajo
viendo lo que está acá abajo dividiendo
lo voy a pasar para arriba entonces me
voy a tomar 12 por un cuarto 12 x cambió
el signo por un cuarto y cuántos esto
bueno si nosotros recordamos cómo se
multiplican reacciones aquí tengo 12
sobre 112 sobre 1 y vamos a multiplicar
directo este por este este por este 12
por unas 12 4 por unas 4 y 12 entre 4 y
12 cuartos es lo mismo que 3 enteros y
tenemos toda la razón 2 entre 4 que ya
sabíamos cuánto es es lo mismo que 3
está padrísima esta idea de dividir
pensando en la multiplicación del
inverso fíjate que aquí me tome de nuevo
este inverso y es justo lo que vamos a
hacer este vídeo multiplicar por el
inverso y es la forma en la que creo que
es mucho más fácil resolver una división
de fracciones de una manera mecánica
ahora vamos a ver si me entiendes porque
me estoy tomando el inverso vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo y bueno antes de
hacer más ejemplos sobre la división de
fracciones no quiero que te espantes con
el inverso con el inverso realmente es
algo muy sencillo por ejemplo si yo
tengo a el inverso de am me lo va a
transformar a 1 entre a lo único que
hago es pasar están dividiendo entre 1
por ejemplo si yo tengo 5 su inverso su
inverso multiplicativo su inverso va a
ser 1 entre 5 ahora esto en caso de que
tengamos un número entero pero si
tenemos un número fraccionario por
ejemplo a entre b y me tomo su inverso
lo único que va a pasar lo único que va
a pasar es que se van a voltear me va a
quedar b / a este pasa abajo este pasa
arriba y se acabó el problema por
ejemplo si yo tengo dos tercios y me
quiero tomar el inverso el inverso
multiplicativo de dos tercios es tres
medios así de fácil así que ahora sí lo
que vamos a estar haciendo es
multiplicando por el inverso de la
fracción que está dividiendo vamos a ver
otro ejemplo qué te parece si tengo dos
tercios dos tercios me gustó entre entre
cinco sextos ok pues lo que hay que
hacer es tomarme este dos tercios
dejarlo tal cual y ahora voy a pasar
esto multiplicando y multiplicando
recuerda que cambió el signo y a éste lo
volteó cálculo su inverso el inverso de
5 sextos
quintos y bueno ahora multiplico este
por este y éste por este y que me va a
quedar 2 por 6 es 12 entre 3 por 5 es 15
y esta fracción esta fracción se puede
simplificar un poco que te parece si yo
divido la parte de arriba entre 3 me va
a quedar 42 entre 34 y ahora voy a
dividir la parte de abajo entre 315
entre 35 recuerda que siempre que tengas
la posibilidad de reducir la fracción
hazlo es un resultado mucho más elegante
cuatro quintos que 12 entre 15 ok otro
ejemplo otro ejemplo imagínate que
tenemos siete octavos siete octavos ya
esto lo divido entre un cuarto entre un
cuarto que nos va a quedar bueno pues ya
sabemos cómo va este asunto siete
octavos por ya éste lo volteó voy a
pasar de dividir a multiplicar por el
inverso que es 4 sobre 1 y ahora sí de
hecho equipo simplificar desde ahorita
cuánto es
pero entre 8 bueno pues esto lo puedo
pasar a uno le puede sacar cuarta y al
ocho depositar cuarta que es dos y me va
a quedar siete medios por uno lo que es
siete medios o bueno recuerda que esto
lo puedes ver también cómo un número
mixto como tres enteros un medio 2 por 3
6 1 y 7 6 3 enteros un medio aquí está
visto de una manera mixta como un número
mixto pero ámbito personal me gusta
mucho más trabajar cuando este tipo de
fracciones con fracciones impropias ok
aquí hay otro ejemplo vamos a hacer
muchos ejemplos más muy bien y como esto
es tan divertido qué te parece si
hacemos a todos los ejemplos que me
quepan en cuatro minutos cinco minutos
que me quedan qué sé yo a veamos a tengo
menos 2 sobre 3 entre entre a 5 sobre 2
ok pues ya sabemos que tenemos que hacer
es sólo queda menos tres entre dos no
wops no no es cierto menos dos entre
tres recuerda que a éste lo dejamos
igual ya esto lo voy a multiplicar este
es un signo de entre de entre ok lo voy
a multiplicar por el inverso de este el
inverso de a se encuentra 2 que es 2
entre 5 a éste si lo cambio y esto me da
menos permanece es menos dos por dos es
cuatro y tres por ciento es 15 fácil a
ver esto me gusta otro más pero más tres
medios tres medios lo voy a dividir
entre un sexto entre un sexto que me da
de resultado esto bueno pues tenemos
tres medios por 6 sobre 1 y esto lo
podemos simplificar de una vez que te
parece si aquí sacó mitad es más déjeme
cambiar de color sacó mitad la mitad de
2 es 1 ok y aquí también sacó mitad la
mitad de 6 es
recuerda que lo que hago arriba al toque
será abajo y 3 por 3 es
99 porque abajo no quedaría un 1
entonces 9 enteros de lujo vamos ser más
ejemplos pero ya no me cabe así que
borremos la pantalla ejemplos más
ejemplos y creo que poco a poco le estás
agarrando más a todo esto a menos veamos
a menos 5 o no que yo 5 menos 5 sobre 7
lo voy a dividir entre a 10 sobre 3
entre 10 sobre 3 y es que haciendo un
buen de ejercicios vas a tener la
facilidad y la rapidez de hacer una
división de fracciones creo que por eso
quiero hacer muchos ejercicios bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que menos 5 entre
7 y a esto a esto lo voy a convertir en
su inverso
por 3 entre 10 se recuerda que lo único
que hago es voltear los y bueno cuantos
esto esto es lo mismo que menos 15 sobre
a 70 y esto se puede simplificar porque
tienen quinta esto es lo mismo que a 15
entre 5 es tres menos tres entre setenta
entre cinco 73 5 es 14 y bueno desde
aquí se podía ver aquí puedes sacar la
quinta que es 1 la quinta que es 2 y me
quedaría a menos 3 entre 14 que es justo
lo que llegamos perfecto a ver hagamos
otro más qué tal si yo pongo un medio
entre menos 3 wahaha cómo resolvemos
esto si yo aquí tengo un número entero
bueno pues recuerda que un número entero
también lo podemos ver como una fracción
esto es lo mismo que un medio entre a y
esto es lo mismo que menos 3 entre 1 ok
estos dos son lo mismo porque es un
entero visto como fracción
utilicemos la propiedad del inversor
este lo pongo aquí pongo un signo de x y
a éste lo volteó y me va a quedar 1
sobre 3 negativo ojo si este número es
negativo su inverso también va a ser
negativo eso es importante y cuanto es
esto pues estos menos 1 sobre 6 recuerda
que es este por este menos 12 mil 36 ok
y qué te parece si ahora pienso en lo
contrario tengo menos 3 tengo ahora un
número entero y este lo divido entre
menos entre un medio entre un medio
positivo voy a tomar justo lo contrario
a donde crees que lleguemos bueno pues
vamos a usar domingo estos menos 3 sobre
1 por ahora me voy a tomar este justo
este de manera inversa el inverso de un
medio es 2 sobre 1 y cuando es esto
bueno esto sólo se pueden cancelar y me
va a quedar menos por más menos 2 36
menos 6 y creo que tiene toda la lógica
del mundo si yo aquí me tomé a este
[ __ ] no es el yo menos 1 en 36 y me lo
tomé al revés
- 6 el inverso multiplicativo ok y
ponemos el pizarrón más ejemplos a ver
qué te parece si yo tomo esto vamos a
ver si podemos crear un poco de
intuición voy a tomarme 2 entre entre un
tercio y bueno creo que ya sabemos de
forma monótona cómo hacer esto esto es 2
x a 2 sobre 1 por el verso de este que
es 3 entre 1 y aquí esto lo quedaría 6
como como puede ser que esté relacionado
2 con un tercio y llegue a 6 esto suena
medio raro pero vamos a recordar las
pizzas imagínate que yo me tomo dos
pizzas tengo una pizza por acá tengo
otra pizza por acá y realmente lo que
estoy diciendo es que a estas pizzas las
voy a dividir en tercios me va a quedar
algo así algo así porque y después algo
así tendría tercios ya está también la
voy a dividido en tercios
y algo así y después algo así y si te
das cuenta obtuve seis pedazos 1231 de
gente medianamente
123456 espero que esto tiene un poquito
de noción o una ligera idea de qué es o
a qué me refiero cuando estoy dividiendo
dos fracciones pero bueno ya casi se me
acaba el tiempo así que vamos a hacer la
última de este vídeo
se me antoja menos 7 entre 2 a esto lo
voy a dividir entre entre otra reacción
negativa entre menos 4 entre 9 que
tenemos que hacer ok primero dejamos a
este tal cual y me queda menos 7 medios
y después pongo aquí el signo de x por
ya esta fracción le encuentro su inversa
la inversa esta fracción es menos 9
entre 4 y ahora sí cuántos esto bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que menos por
menos me va a dar más más el mar no lo
voy a poner 7 x 9 63 63 entre 2 x 4 s 8
63 octavos y esto no se puede reducir
esta es la última y bueno creo que ya
estás preparado de una manera muy
mecánica y hasta de una manera muy
rápida a cómo dividir fracciones
entonces ve al módulo de fracciones y
práctica ahora por tu cuenta
diviértete